[موسيقى]
أمريكي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مدينا
كان جدي يعمل لدى فورد وعملت جدتي
لدى كرايسلر كلاهما جاء
من الجنوب من
خلال عملهما كعاملين في السيارات
تعلمنا الكثير عنه  الاتحاد
حول عمل صناعة السيارات
، والعمل الجاد من
أجل أن تكون قادرًا على الحصول على عيش جيد ،
لديه بعض الأشياء اللطيفة في
الوقت الحالي بالطريقة التي كانت بها الأشياء التي
تبحث عن صناعة السيارات
جيدة جدًا
في 07 كان لدينا انهيار
عندما  كل شيء حدث في الاقتصاد ،
قاموا بتسريح الكثير من عمال كرايسلر
مقابل جنرال إلكتريك ،
كنت جزءًا من تلك التسريح في 07
ولكن ما زلنا قادرين على جني الأموال ،
لم يكن ذلك بمثابة تسريح سيء لنا ،
نعم لن أرغب أبدًا في الاستغناء عن العمل
مرة أخرى ، ليس شعورًا جيدًا
ألا تعرف ما إذا كنت ستحصل على
وظيفة للعودة إلى
[موسيقى]
ساتا ديترويت
أجنبي
أجنبي كانت
هذه المنطقة مليئة بالمنازل
ومصنع باكارد أثناء الحرب العالمية
الثانية وما بعدها  كانت الحرب العالمية الثانية
ستوظف حوالي 30000
كان هذا مشغولًا في بعض الأحيان من
24 إلى الخمسينيات من القرن الماضي
بسبب ازدهار الصناعات في
مدينة ديترويت
والأجور المرتفعة جدًا التي
يكسبها العمال الآن هذه المنازل ستصل إلى
25000 آه بالدولار الحالي
في المنزل بأكمله 25
نعم نعم  منزل كامل لإغلاق
الصفقة مقابل
نعم لشراء المنزل بأكمله لشراء
المنزل
بأكمله طوال العمر 25000.000 سيشترون
العديد من المنازل في هذا
الحي بالذات ، افترض الناس في ديترويت أن
صناعة السيارات
ستستمر في التزايد
مزدهرة وكانت مزدهرة للغاية
، لم تكن جيدة للعمال
، حيث أن العمال ذوي الياقات الزرقاء هناك
عدد أقل بكثير من الوظائف الآن مما كان عليه
الحال في المدينة ، فقد فقدت حوالي ثلثي
سكانها
على الأقل.  ثلثي
وظائفها هو ظل لما كانت
عليه في السابق
ديترويت ليس بالأمر غير المعتاد ، فهي ليست مركزًا
للابتكارات التكنولوجية بالطريقة التي قد تكون بها
سان خوسيه
أو سياتل بحيث
لم تستحوذ ديترويت على بعض
الصناعات الجديدة  ستحل محل
العمالة
في صناعة السيارات
[الموسيقى] في
كاليفورنيا أو
وادي السيليكون الذي تعرفه لأطول
فترة ، لقد تم تحديد الولايات المتحدة حقًا من خلال
الصناعة التحويلية
وربما أفضل مثال على ذلك في صناعة
السيارات وهذا بالطبع لم يعد هو
الحال بالنسبة لنا  الآن يتم تعريفها حقًا من خلال
تقنيتها ،
أعتقد بالتأكيد أنها
ذات قيمة لا تصدق لشركتي
إذا بدأت الشركة هنا ،
فأنت تعرف بشكل لا يصدق
كتلة فائقة القيمة من المستثمرين والمستشارين
المحتملين والكثير من المواهب التي يجب توظيفها في وادي السيليكون.
أعتقد أن الكثير
من مفاهيم الابتكار في
وادي السيليكون ستبدأ في الانتشار في
جميع أنحاء
العالم ، والسبب في ذلك هو أننا أعتقد
أننا لم نعد مقيدين بالجغرافيا ،
وفي الحقيقة
تحدياتنا عالمية وفرصنا
عالمية ، وبالتالي فإن
هذه القضايا هي  يتم حلها بشكل أفضل من
قبل سكان العالم ، فالعديد منا يبدأ
شركات
بهدف الحصول على نوع من الوصول العالمي
وبالنسبة لي فإن
شركتي هي  الاستجابة للكوارث
الطبيعية وهذه الأحداث ليست خاصة
بالولايات المتحدة ، فقد شهدنا
الأعاصير والأعاصير وحرائق الغابات التي حطمت الرقم القياسي في
جميع أنحاء
العالم
خلال السنوات القليلة الماضية
[موسيقى]
أنت